you're watching is what we've got for
you on this week's show
an aerial revolution in farming Angela's
looking at the robots that could join
the workforce in the field meanwhile
world-famous supermodel Natalia
Vodianova tells me what it feels like to
jump from fashion to tech and you've
waited nearly 10 years for it but
finally the last Guardian has arrived
hello and welcome to the copper box
arena in London this place was one of
the Olympic sites in 2012 this week
though it's hosting technology fans at
TechCrunch Disrupt London 2016 think of
it as a big event for entrepreneurs
speakers investors and a world famous
model as it turns out have more on that
later because first we're headed to the
farm with Angela she's been looking at
the technology making farming more
efficient traditional farming is
changing tending to livestock and
growing crops could soon be the job of
robots
that's according to engineering staff at
Harper Adams University they are
adapting farm machinery to create
autonomous alternatives to do
time-consuming tasks self-driving
tractors and robotic harvesting systems
are just a couple of concepts well
underway well these new machines can be
made so that they carry out these tasks
a lot more efficiently than we do at the
moment right now we spread fertilizer
over the whole field and chemicals that
are going off target but with these new
machines we can be able to do what I
called intelligently targeted inputs so
it's a lot more accurate and a lot more
efficient than the current practices
Jonah's being petted see how heavy used
to break crop the engineers say the
advantage of this is greater precision
and avoiding damage to the crops by
flying over them instead of driving over
them
and here is another idea in development
to protect crops researchers at
Liverpool John Moores University are
working on a project which uses high
power lasers to keep pests away
they say the fence of laser light will
provide an alternative to poison some of
the companies behind the new
technologies think the robots will do a
better job of quality control but those
in the field think the human element
will always be needed and the cost of
the machinery also out of reach for some
businesses it's very exciting time to be
involved in farming and I still think
there is a massive role for the actual
farmer for the hands-on farmer that the
decision-making part of the job no two
farms in England are the same and
there's this so every single farm is
different so I think different farmers
can embrace technology in different ways
so yeah I don't think it's going to be a
blanket rollout of all technology
research from various universities and
think tanks predict that around 11
million jobs in the UK are at risk of
automation for some the transition to
full autonomy is already in progress but
for others the idea of taking the farmer
out of the field is still a little
far-fetched
Angela barns Sky News stay with us still
to come
supermodel Natalia Vodianova also known
as supernova will be telling me how
she's creating a new kind of social
currency that's coming right up after a
roundup of this week's techniques
it seems the tech industry still has a
problem with sexism a survey by Sky News
and online magazine the pool of more
than 500 women working in the sector
found 39% believed they had been denied
a significant opportunity at work
because of their gender Microsoft
Twitter Facebook and Google's YouTube
are joining forces to help stop the
spread of terrorist propaganda online
they're creating a type of digital
database and say their plan could stop
videos that are blocked on one platform
from then appearing on another Virgin
Galactic has completed a successful test
flight of its new spaceship VSS unity it
comes more than two years after the
company's predecessor space crime
broke apart and crashed in the mojave
desert in southern california killing a
co-pilot and a us-based biotech company
has developed a special kind of garnet
says can spray a person's own stem cells
on to severe burns so their skin can
heal itself renova care claims the skin
gun technology has successfully treated
more than 40 patients in tests so far it
could one day offer an alternative to
traditional and painful skin grafting
stick around for our games review it's
all going off in the kitchen but first
now this section of the others could
start our valleys well if entrepreneurs
showcasing their ideas and their apps
and their products including supermodel
Natalia Vodianova you're expecting us
hello told us about your app that you
launched well lb is the platform and
enough so we bring the power of social
and digital to charities and brands it
allows people around the world and
especially young audience who we're
focusing on to to do something good
daily and although it's an app that's
promoting good deeds yes exactly
I've heard you say that this is a new
kind of social currency so is it reward
based charity giving whether I donate
would I create what I share I get one
point and that grows my score and that
score also turns into social currency
the
turns into actual coins that then you
can spend in the love shop so love shop
is the first online retail space where
you can literally shop with love I'm
interested to know what your first
impressions of the tech industry were
when you began working in app
development well it's very expensive
with my first impression and very
competitive space so it's very difficult
to to find really good developers as
this project being very challenging for
you to jump from modeling from fashion
into that one into tech yes because it's
a very new field for me but into world
of philanthropy no because I started my
own charity organization twelve years
ago so I know really inside out what
it's what the charity needs as being
famous been a hindrance at all because a
lot of people might say that it's an
advantage because you can have celebrity
backing with your product but have you
found that to be true or have you found
that it's works against you sometimes it
works it's it's a good thing but
actually it can be an obstacle because
people especially being you know a woman
and and and also model and being in the
fashion industry that is supposed to be
very frivolous you know III it's
difficult to prove that you are very
very serious about it how would we found
being woman I know it's hard to prepare
because we've never been meant
it definitely brings attention but then
you know for good or for bad I'm just
trying to do absolute my best but I do
find it that it's it's difficult now
time for this week's games review where
Chris has been busy wiping out zombies
and creating culinary havoc just for us
Dead Rising 4 takes place in the town
from the original Dead Rising it has the
character from the original Dead Rising
frank west who's back in Willow Mac if
you've not played a dead rising game
before and you own an Xbox I don't know
how you've avoided this but basically
he's a photojournalist who's covered
Wars you know haha anyone who's played
it before gether it's very hilarious but
he goes around dispatching hordes of
zombies in ridiculous crazy inventive
ways it would take a Christmas miracle
for old Frank to Seba
like in this one you can fire a gun the
first fireworks everywhere or there's a
giant mech suit that you can get in it
runs out of juice eventually but it's
still pretty ridiculous when you're you
see like 100 zombies have just been like
dispatched by you just stamping onto the
ground that's pretty fun and that's the
gist of the game just go around and get
rid of as many zombies as you can
there's a plot characters and all that
stuff but it's not really the main focus
of this game let the sleigh ride begin
The Last Guardian is a game that almost
become vaporware which is a term that
basically means a game that's never
going to come out
and now it's out on the PlayStation for
exists and it's amazing and stunning and
beautiful as everything you'd sort of
hoped for and all that time you play a
young boy hangs around with a giant
man-eating monster called trico who's
also ridiculously cute in the truck a
catbird is what you do is you have to
solve problems and move forward
essentially it's a beautiful stunning
world but the gist of it is how do I
keep progressing with this giant beast
like that's now my friend but you get to
know the beast as you go along and you
both become friends
overcooked is unquestionably the best
couch co-op game this year and they're
releasing a free update a free update
that brings in holiday stuff so you can
play as a reindeer there's eight new
levels that you can play through and a
cool new way to cook which is a
flamethrower what you do you and a group
of friends get together and you create
food you're all chefs
ideally four if you would be playing all
in the same room it's the first time I
think I've ever fully appreciated why
chefs run their kitchens like a military
organization there always seem weird to
me we're not like yes chef and running
around is like come on I've made dinner
it's not loud but then you just try
playing this game and it's ridiculous
you end up shouting at your friends
doing I need tomorrow's now why have you
not chopped the tomorrow they should be
there we have a system that's it from us
here at TechCrunch Disrupt London we'll
be back next week hoping join us then
but in the meantime you can watch any of
our swipe episodes on our YouTube
playlist just type in spy nice white
and stay up-to-date with all the latest
categories throughout the week of SCI
news on mobile tablet catch up spy cute
and snapchat where everywhere
see you soon bye bye
[Music]